ya tenemos los finalistas de super bowl
que se puede decir de ese partido que
viene es la gran cita de deporte en eeuu
un deporte que mueve masas en este país
y por primera vez después de cinco
temporadas los mariscales de campo tom
brady y patrick mayor no van a estar en
un superbowl los ángeles rams van a
recibir en su estadio los cincinnati
bengals en un duelo de dos equipos si
quieren acabar con larga sequía sin
proclamarse campeones comenzamos con los
rams que superaron anoche a los san
francisco fueron a jmr psh en la liga
nacional después de remontar 10 puntos
la franquicia de california perdida por
17 a 10 al comienzo del último cuarto al
final victoria por 20 a 17 para los rams
que vuelven a un super bowl cuatro años
después pero en aquella ocasión cayeron
contra los pacers no ganan el campeonato
desde
1999 mayor aún fue la remontada de los
bengaleses que dieron vuelta a un
partido que perdían por 18 puntos en
casa de los kansas city chiefs uno de
los grandes favoritos el equipo de
cincinnati se impuso por 27-24 en el
tiempo extra y así clasifican para por
tercera vez a un súper bowl es el
primero en 33 años la final sera domingo
13 de febrero en casa de los rams
escuchamos a los entrenadores
este escenario icónico es realmente
único tendremos una agenda de viaje un
poco más fácil para nosotros ya que
hemos viajado por todo el país durante
el transcurso del año durante la mayor
parte
es un equipo especial capaz de hacer
cosas especiales creímos desde el
comienzo sin importar si la gente
confiaba en nosotros o no pero lo
hicimos así que no estamos sorprendidos
aquí era en donde debíamos estar